hey youtubers it's Charlie we learned a
whole bunch of stuff about what's
happening with episode 1 comic-con
footage as well as a new character that
they're casting so let's break it down
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so if you didn't see there was all
this Comic Con news that dropped
yesterday for all of DC TV but buried in
all the descriptions of new footage
they're going to be dropping they talked
about the flash
episode one so right off the bat I'll
say the Flash's Comic Con panel is
happening Saturday at 5:10 p.m. so it's
happening on Saturday night instead of
Friday night so that's the first big
thing to remember is that all the DC TV
trailers all that stuff is going to be
happening on Saturday instead of Friday
it's usually been on Friday nights in
past years but here's the description of
the flash episode 1 so they say running
up against an evil time remnant of
yourself is something no one should ever
have to do but that's exactly what face
Barry Allen aka the flash as he fought
to save the life of his fiancee iris
West
from the god of speed known as Savitt
are Barry's victory was short-lived
however as an unbalanced Speed Force
began to wreak havoc on central city
forcing Barry to sacrifice himself for
the greater good with the fastest man
alive now trapped inside an extra
dimensional energy in unknown dangers
lurking in the shadows it will be up to
team flash to free Barry from his own
personal hell join cast members Grant
Gustin
Jesse Martin Tom Cavanagh Candice Patton
danielle Panabaker
Carlos Valdes and Kenyon Lyons Dale and
the producers of The CW's highest-rated
series at their annual Comic Con panel
and then pretty much all the shows are
just like ok a special video
presentation we're going to be dropping
footage so everybody go crazy we'll talk
about that in a second but they also
revealed that there's a new character
they're casting right now that's going
to be relatively cg they basically say
that it's going to give the special
effects people a lot of headaches
because it's going to look really cool
and saboteur was largely CG it was like
a person walking around in a practical
suit that looked like this but they had
to add a lot of CG they did the same
thing for zoom so it's not that much
different from previous seasons you want
to have a villain that looks really cool
on screen but that also
works without CG so I think they're
trying to fine-tune that this season but
let's talk about that synopsis first
rescuing Barry from his own personal
hell so there are a couple things about
this description that make you wonder
what's going on because it does make it
sound like everybody else is going to
try and pull Barry out of the Speed
Force rather than him coming out by
himself which is kind of exciting when
you think about it it'd be like a Speed
Force prison break but the big question
is at the end of last season Barry's
mother the Speed Force wormhole alien
that looked like his mother said that it
wouldn't be a personal hell like it was
before so there are a couple of things
that are misleading in this description
but I do like the idea the team flash
rescues Barry in that first episode so
it'd be a version of rebirth where they
pull them out of the Speed Force you get
to have that moment with Wally with Iris
but there's just a big question about
what that would do to the Speed Force
because they say it's unbalanced Barry
went in to balance it so what happens
when he leaves does that mean it goes
back to being unbalanced probably not
it'll probably be relatively fine but
they say the dangers are lurking in the
shadows they're talking about the new
villains they're talking about the other
rogues that are going to resurface in
the absence of Barry Allen because just
like when Batman isn't in Gotham and
everybody knows that he's not in Gotham
crime usually rises about two hundred
percent even though there's still a
flash in Central City everybody knows
that it's not the Barry Allen flash that
they're afraid of so it presents this
perfect opportunity for Wally to cut his
teeth trying to learn to be a better
flash as well as the Rogues trying to
push their luck like oh it's the junior
version of the flash we can totally get
away with all these heists that we
didn't think we could pull before the
real danger lurking in the shadow in the
CG characters that they're casting right
now sounds like it could be the thinker
but I wouldn't be surprised if they
start the season with different villains
and then they get to the thinker later I
do like the idea that they tried to
start with a different version of an
evil flash last season but he only
lasted for a couple episodes and he kind
of came off like the joke the rival
actually could have been a pretty cool
villain if they to let him kill or take
down a couple people before Wally West
tried to trap him so just don't be
surprised if they start the season with
a new villain that they take down in the
first couple of episodes
and then that paves the way for bigger
villains to surface because I think it's
okay if they hold back the big bad till
later in the season as long as you feel
his presence you feel I'm pulling the
strings but you don't want to hold them
back too much the way they held backs
avatar because then you're hanging
everything on the idea that your reveal
is going to be the biggest payoff ever
and sometimes that doesn't work out it's
really easy to pay off reverse-flash
season one was a slam dunk season two
was zoom was pretty cool too but I don't
think that's avatar future flash landed
quite as well as they hope they would so
even though there always be big twists
big reveals like oh my god I never
thought it was this person they'll
probably try to introduce the villain in
a slightly different way so let me know
in the comments how do you want them to
deal with villains this season do you
want to meet the big bad in the first
couple of episodes it just have him be
around for the entire season or would
you rather see a bunch of different
villains and then see the big bad
surface the CG character that they're
casting could be the thinker but there's
still a bunch of minor flash rogues that
they haven't done before they always
tend to pick people's names and mix and
match things so they could always take a
relatively minor villain from the comics
and turn them into something much bigger
but because they said they're not doing
a lot of evil speedsters like they did
at the beginning of last season I'm just
guessing it's going to be somebody from
the rogues gallery like there's a
character called the changeling it is
not Beast Boy it's like a different
villain that changes himself they could
be doing something like that I feel like
they're going to use this season of DC
TV to test out what they can do with the
Titans TV show because Greg Berlanti is
producing all the DC TV stuff
but they're also doing Titans and they
don't have any footage for that TV show
yet just because they're getting ready
to shoot the pilot in September Comic
Con is at the end of July and a couple
weeks so obviously there's nothing to
show so what they might do is they might
answer a couple questions while
comic-con is happening but I don't
expect them to talk too much about it
during the other DC TV panels but I can
already see all the comments piling on
why is Tom Felton not on the cast list
of people coming to comic-con it's
totally possible when season four picks
up he's not around he's moved on and
then just comes back to guest
every once in a while because really big
guest stars tend to only stay on for one
season but like Eddie came back a couple
times during season two he came back
during season three and they killed him
off and we know that Julian is still in
love with Kaitlyn so whatever they do
with the characters they'll explain it
in Episode one in a really simple way
they tend to move the plot forward quite
a bit and then flashback to all the
stuff that's happened in the past three
months since the last season finished
like oh this is what we've been doing
since berry went into the Speed Force so
the only thing that would make me really
mad is if Kaitlyn is already back on
Team flash everybody's happy and there
aren't any really big problems outside
of the new Rogues that have surfaced
while Barry's been gone so let me know
in the comments what do you think about
the idea of this Speed Force Prison
Break that they're talking about in the
synopsis tom felton not being on the
cast list in the CG character that
they're casting right now but if you
guys want I will do Comic Con videos
like this for the other TV shows there's
a Young Justice panel that's happening
on a different day so what will happen
during Comic Con is obviously there's
all the trailer videos that I'll do for
the new footage they drop most of that
will be on Saturday but they'll also be
a bunch of casting announcements they'll
be stuff happening through the week so
what will happen is the week before
Comic Con I'll do more preview videos
for what's going to be happening but
I'll remind everyone to turn video
alerts on so you don't miss any of the
videos because I'll be posting stuff all
day long throughout Comic Con and it's
like a four day marathon
so it's going to be a lot of fun but
there's also a lot of Marvel TV stuff
that they drop for Comic Con so just let
me know in the comments what kind of
Comic Con stuff you guys want me to do
right now because it's still a couple
weeks away there'll also be some extra
special giveaways happening that we just
like I do every year congratulations to
the latest winner dark hound 1382 please
private message me so I can get your
contact details in while you wait for
everything to post you can click here
for the Rick and Morty official season 3
trailer we finally got a premiere date
on that so I talked about that during
that video and you can click here for my
non-spoilery spider-man homecoming
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you